uh researchers at Stanford kind of um
wanted to see how people's beliefs about
their own Fitness would shape how they
responded to endurance exercise
um so they gave people a real uh genetic
test it looked at the crop one gene
which is associated with um kind of uh
cardiovascular fitness you know and
endurance if you have the kind of good
version of the gene like you find it a
bit easier or more comfortable to do
exercise things like your kind of
internal body temperature just stays in
the kind of comfortable range a bit
longer Gene you know like um yeah
exactly it's great great to have if you
have it I'm a glut and that's like my
advice is I just I can go to buffets and
just eat and eat meat so I hope I have
that Gene or if I don't I hope crispr is
making some progress because I would
like to engineer that into me
but here's the thing that you should
remember then
um because so they did the real genetic
test but they gave people false feedback
so they told some people you have the
good Gene good version of the jeans some
people were told they're the bad version
of the Gene and then they did their kind
of endurance exercise and what the
researchers found was that yeah like the
gene does have an effect but so did
people's expectations of uh whether they
had the genes so this this feedback was
sham feedback so some who had the good
version were told they had the bad
version vice versa and actually those
expectations independently affected how
people did the exercise
um and you know in some cases According
to some of the physiological measures
the expectations were actually more
important than the effects of the gene
itself so when they were looking at like
the efficiency of the lungs well that
depended more on the expectations that
you had the good Gene than whether you
actually had the good Gene that's
interesting to your experience of being
like a rapacious for yeah they did
exactly the same experiment looking at
people's
um a gene that was associated with um
satiety so whether people feel they need
to eat more to be full
um and again they found that actually
those expectations did shape how much
people ate
um but also shaped like the response of
the uh the gut the hormonal response
there was one particular hormone that's
linked to satiety that was very closely
linked to the expectations of whether
they would be full or not thanks to this
Gene so you know again it's like it's
like I said just in the answer to your
previous question like I'm not claiming
that like our genes don't matter because
they did have an effect too but what you
can what you can see here is that
actually even if you have the bad Gene
you don't have to see it as being
deterministic in some way like you can
accept that actually your expectations
are also playing a role and then you can
look for ways to kind of change those
expectations